so the second game and I let's go if all
I don't know what okay played this the
last time I remember right the Russell
limo okay let's vary a bit with them
transposing our we fire transposing to
the c3 line yeah this is a funny funny
set up on 95 black really plays 98 and
some lines so if i go d for now as thou
yeah awesome tactic ok it cannot be bad
really i mean even if if he takes him
Wow
really we didn't take five feet x yeah
he must take only five with the night
after that 95 miles 25 or 25 and over
okay he's got them he's got a pretty
pretty decent development
looks looks a bit strange but ok it's
not bad but that d 6 and so on it's it's
not so also terrible ok how to how to
proceed him the bishop is serve exposed
him or maybe Queen f3m plus the
sleepless loss that's ok preparing
Bishop f4 and getting the queen of the
default so I have maybe a rookie one
later ok get let's take this temple
yeah you can go go to c5 when I need you
you know move the bishop again yes I'm
not so sure if this is really am helping
em the queen is not so badly placed on
g3 maybe you can go Bishop Dyer there
should be six out there should be six or
so I was an interesting an interesting
way to go maybe maybe maybe even here
and then go f3e mf3 and possibly Bishop
deform the bishop is very well placed on
deform attacking the g7 square or taking
the square so that's nonsense I mean
putting our pressure on g7 so that even
made some are possible ok I don't mind
should I play this something better even
ok this is it's not bad this is not bad
i can I can do that okay of course I
don't want to take I want to keep the
pawn on d6 and not help them to improve
the pawn structure maybe that's also 95
yeah I can exchange it's not it's not
terrible it's probably a better for wide
yeah come on let's let's play an endgame
here don't need to play for for middle
of the time because so it is it's
somewhat better for me because of the d6
porn so how to how do you protect it now
I can probably just take it
36 is some attacked very often and 98 is
no move just 95 besides you don't defend
don't define down in this passive
fashion
hmm probably grab it yeah to a4 maybe I
don't want want the rukon c2 I mean okay
he can put it on c2 anyway but at least
on on a for the Stratford takes the ball
on on be too I should I go 95 95 this
night is really a stupid piece am I
don't want to exchange it the night is
just looking at the for porn which is
yeah very well defended the 94 maybe can
go to c5 even later
mmm you know let's go how many do to you
three time check yeah okay exchanging
one pair of rope says it's not bad ok go
here so that the night cannot count to
f4 I'm just playing against this piece
ok and now let's get the Knight to c4 on
c4 detects a five and it protects be too
it is light is on h5 doing doing
basically nothing so night c4 you can
play a 4 but I have 95 this is an
important move so on you basically now
the rookies attacked and f7 SS hanging
and a 4 also so this basically
everything hanging so let's let's take
first oh no this is the simplest yeah
cliff check first no take it I was
threatening mate so it needs to react
first let's just take here
rook be a them to stop the aid attacking
before check now the d3 night protects
b2f form and the text before so not much
more you can can ask of 11 I design yes
this was some somehow a very one-sided
position after the opening I don't I
don't know how how this this is supposed
to be played maybe some other move here
I don't know this this looks I don't
know if looks good for what if you ask
me opening up the position maybe maybe
d6 here trying to defend um it wasn't
wasn't done I walk in the park this game
for black yeah thanks for watching